^- Hi, Mom.
(laughing)
Brandon!
(playful music)
- Hi, I'm Michelle.
- I'm Brandon.
- Today, we're going to be making kimchi
for the very first time.
- [Brandon] Kimchi is a traditional Korean side dish,
made from fermented vegetables and a bunch of spice.
- It's like the foundation of Korean food.
- It's a very pungent dish.
- You can eat it with like any meal.
- I never thought I really had the skills to make it.
- Watching my mom do it,
it just looked like a lot of physical labor.
- So this time my mom is the one teaching us
how to make kimchi.
- I've actually met Brandon's mom.
She's just the nicest person ever.
- I'm super nervous.
She'll probably embarrass me.
- Brandon!
Brandon!
It's too big.
^(speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- First time kimchi making, let's do it.
- My name is, I am Brandon's mom.
I'm very exciting today.
^(speaking foreign language)
- Brandon and Michelle, are you today ready?
- Yeah, sure.
- As ready as I'll ever be.
- This morning we actually did the first step already.
It was a lot of salt and water and soaking the cabbages in.
^- [Producer] It was the first time you did it, right?
- I didn't do it, my mom did it.
^I just watched, visual learner.
^(speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
^- Thanks mom.
^(speaking foreign language)
- Sweet rice flour.
- [Michelle] I didn't realize we
had to use flour to make kimchi.
^(speaking foreign language)
^(laughing)
- Fellas, I'm ready.
^(speaking foreign language)
- Try, Brandon.
- Here your finger, here.
- Okay, I got it.
That's a bad knife.
- No, very good.
- [Michelle] Oh my God.
- Brandon, power.
Ooh, too big.
Okay, stop.
Michelle.
- It's harder than you think.
- Is this how skinny is should be?
- Brandon.
(laughing)
- Good job, Brandon.
- Weren't you a food writer?
- Shh.
- Brandon, C.
(laughing)
- Michelle, B.
- Oh, I feel when you're a parent,
you get better cooking skills.
Like kimchi pad-awon.
- Yeah.
(speaking foreign language)
- I think I'd be better at this.
Oh no, nevermind.
^(laughing)
- There's nothing sweeter than the approval of a Korean mom.
- I've been trying for the approval, 22 years.
- This one is just option.
- Michelle's bad too.
^(speaking foreign language)
- She like scrapes with her knife off her palm.
- I know.
- I like it.
^(speaking foreign language)
- Grinding it?
Grating not grinding.
(speaking foreign language)
- I could do this.
- [Michelle] I love ginger.
^- Can I do it?
^(speaking foreign language)
- Brandon, you try.
- Ooh, yeah, I'm good at this.
Is it A?
- Yeah, A plus.
- Now that we grated up all the onions, ginger, and pear,
^we just put it into our original base.
^- Literally every Korean mom has one of these.
(speaking foreign language)
- How much?
- Hmm, I don't know.
(laughing)
- OG kimchi is when you just eye it, and you just know.
- It's like mini salted shrimp.
- Yeah.
- It smells like the fish part of the market.
- [Michelle] This looks way thicker
than I thought kimchi was.
^(speaking foreign language)
- I would buy a squeeze bottle of this.
- This is legit.
You know because we have gloves on.
- [Michelle] Yes.
^(speaking foreign language)
- You have to rub it in while mixing it?
- Yeah.
- It's like fun cause you get really hands on.
^(speaking foreign language)
Thank you.
- I feel like they've gotten closer.
(laughing)
And I feel really awkward being here.
^- I think we're going to go shopping later without you.
^(speaking foreign language)
- Mm.
- Good?
- Mm-hmm.
^(speaking foreign language)
- My mind is blown.
I didn't know it was so deliberate.
- I thought the cabbage gets thrown in,
and you just mixed it around.
^- Yeah!
^Wow, honestly I did not know this is how it worked.
^(speaking foreign languague)
- Inside, okay.
^- This is our kimchi container, just to first to one.
^- Start from the back, take one layer.
^(speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- Alright, here we go.
Throw it on there.
- Brandon.
^(speaking foreign language)
- It'll be more tender now.
Seeing how complicated this is, seeing how long it takes,
makes you appreciate all the mom's out there making kimchi.
- Don't push it.
- Okay (laughs).
- It's your baby, your kimchi baby.
- [Brandon] Gotta be gentle, just a baby.
^And there we go.
^(speaking foreign language)
Last one.
- [Michelle] Kimchi for days.
Oh my God, I'm so excited, it's so beautiful.
I could eat this whole thing.
- This is traditional OG kimchi.
(laughing)
- This is really good.
^- It's the love, you taste the love.
^(speaking foreign language)
- I actually feel like I leveled up as a Korean.
I'm definitely going to KaKaoTalk my mom,
tell her some cheesy thank you
^for doing this for so many years.
^(speaking foreign language)
- To actually make it definitely really special.
^(calming music)
^(laughing)
- She forgot an ingredient.
- [Off Camera Woman] What is that?
- [Brandon] Just garlic.